one of these has got to be dog food they  all look like earthquake food I spin the  cans and when it limbs on the red one I  eat that no corn peas corn oh I don't  want any of the small ones oh [ __ ] the  small one  it sounds gelatinous best by September  2018 so we're good  Oh God you didn't tell me  nice dog food you may hear it I'm so  nervous  well I don't think I like that there's  mold that back could be corn know I know  yeah well what is that it's not hot dogs  and some sort of animal food it's not  cool peaches I don't want any more to  eat the whole thing  no I can't do that no I don't I'm  lactose intolerant I'm not eating the  whole can of condensed milk how weird  what a mindfuck